session on division one good morning
everyone
as always we have to read the commercial
statement
as chairman of division one of the house
finance committee i find that due to the
state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the coba 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session pertaining to
division budget matters
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should email
lba underscore fiscal at
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting and
assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
and we will as always start the meeting
with a roll call attendance
if you're remote you need to state your
presence
and whether anyone is in the room with
you during the meeting
and that's required by the right to know
law
we are in room 202. to my left
is vice chairman tracy emmerich to his
left is representative peter leishman
to my right is representative jerry
griffin
i believe representative taberge is in
the car on his way
uh good morning representative hatch
good morning madam chair i'm at my home
in gorham in the basement and my
bride is amongst us somewhere here thank
you
we'll do our best to get you out of the
basement this week for some time
representative walls well i'm at my home
in beau and my daughter and my husband
are elsewhere in the house
nowhere near me thank you
this morning we have with us the
governor's budget director matt malou
and i think we have
should be dj's dj bet in court online dj
commissioner nick lopez
commissioner ricknopolis is online for
sure
and i'm going to promote them to
panelists
i'm looking for your techie so i can get
my room 205 ryan is in there
i know we had a little technical
difficulty ourselves ken
good morning mr chairman okay
representative weiler just came through
he's also having a little bit of
technical
difficulty this morning uh what page are
we on in house bill 2 we're going to be
discussing
the family leave provision in house bill
2.
page 30 and section 69 i've asked matt
to go through this and dj it's nice to
see you remotely
i've been wanting to talk to you about
the fact you're letting ava grow like a
weed
too fast much much much too fast much
too fast
all right dj we want to do this kind of
like a
bill hearing and i think you can put on
your
former rep hat so we want to start and i
told matt disc
go through every section section at a
time tell us what it says
there may be questions as we go along
and if there
are i will let people ask their
questions so we're at the bottom of page
section 69 there's only a couple of
lines there but
whoever wants to start going through
that please
sure madam chairman if we may just begin
with a few opening remarks
on how uh important this section of hb2
is and there's a lot of history here
and dj will speak to this a bit more as
well but
governor sununu first introduced this
voluntary paid leave plan in his budget
two years ago
we committed then to deliver this to the
people of new hampshire
without an income tax and we're here
again two years later
to follow through on that same
commitment voluntary
paid leave using the state workforce
to drive down market premiums for other
private employers
and to do it without an income tax in
the granite state
this is an opportunity to be a workforce
driver
to attract young families to new
hampshire and
ultimately provide these benefits
not just for the largest businesses that
are already finding ways to accomplish
this
by self-insuring but also delivering it
to the small
and mid-sized businesses throughout the
state we have a very dynamic proposal
that leverages both the state and the
private market
and we're confident that this is a
productive path forward for the state
and from there i'll turn it over to dj
and then we're happy to go through the
bill
okay matt thank you very much dj why
don't we turn to the
top of page 31 because basically it's
just the title at the bottom of page 30
and um
line 4 begins the purpose and policy
do you want to kind of address that
section so if you could do line 4
through 22 or 321 we'll see if we have
any questions
sure madam chairman what i can also do
as well if i may is i prepared some
remarks this morning for you that kind
of just lays the overview of the plan
uh highlights some of its features and
then um
and then we can obviously i'm gonna have
matt lead the section by section but we
can
answer questions and support him as well
so if if i may madam chairman just very
briefly
as you know in my previous role in the
governor's office i was an advocate for
approaching paid family medical leave
and the approach that is before you
today
however in my rule my new role over at
the insurance department i'm here this
morning to be
a resource to uh the committee and to
highlight some of the
more prominent provisions of this plan
than obviously as i said to answer any
questions that you may have
so the structure that is before you this
morning is similar to
many of the previous proposals the
governor in the governor's office has
put forward in the past with the most
prominent
and fundamental feature being that this
program will be administered by
a private insurer who will serve as the
state's vendor for the program
there has been at least two proposals
prior to this and some of the details
have
evolved over time and so i'm going to
try to break this
conversation into two pieces uh the
first piece will be how
it works and then the second piece will
be
how individuals and businesses will
access the product
and then what the coverage will entail
so before i take you through the plan i
would note that many of the features
and adjustments to this plan came as the
result of a request for
information that the insurance
department put forward
in 2018 and it seeks to incorporate
the feedback from the insurance industry
on how best to approach these types of
insurance
products the first feature to note is
that access to this coverage
is universal for state employees this
will be a benefit provided to them by
the state
and those approximately 10 000 employees
will serve as the foundation
of the risk pool for this product for
businesses
businesses will have the flexibility to
opt into the coverage for their
employees
for those businesses that choose to
participate they will retain the
flexibility
to determine how they want the premiums
to be handled that is to say
they can either choose to provide this
as a fully paid benefit to their
employees
they can choose to split the cost with
their employees
or they can have the employee pay for
the coverage entirely on their own
if the business does choose to
participate
this plan creates a business enterprise
tax credit
that will be used to incentivize
participation
which obviously has the intended desire
to
further drive down premiums fifty
percent of the premium that an employer
pays for this coverage
can be claimed as a credit against the
bet
so dj yes what section am i going to
find that bet tax credit in in hb2
i'm at a little bit of a disadvantage
representative i have an older version
of this
matt if you could help me yes that is on
page 40
section 74. details the terms of the bet
tax credit
and we'll come back to that we'll come
back to that thank you matt
thank you dj you betcha so um
so again so that's the that's the tax
credit piece
if a business chooses not to participate
or if the individual is an independent
contractor
or simply wants to access this product
entirely on their own
they will have that access to individual
coverage
premiums for the individual opt-in group
will be stabilized by a premium
stabilization reserve fund
and uh anticipating the question matt do
you want to cite that section
yes i will one second and let me find
that
we're giving matt lot to do today that
is
on page 38 it is within the same section
uh it is line 15 which is 282
dash b colon 5. awesome
thank you matt so this model of a
premium stabilization reserve fund
is based on the state's medicaid
expansion program
where the portion of the insurance
premium tax derived from plans offered
under the granted advantage program are
used to pay
the non-federal share so this mechanism
will also help to limit the weekly
premiums for individuals in this group
to five dollars or less per pay week
i just take this opportunity to
highlight that five dollars per pay week
and where that number came from
so as i said in my previous role i was
heavily involved in this
in the governor's office and that five
dollars per pay
per pay period number came from
advocates of paid family leave who had
done these types of
uh programs and put together these types
of products in other parts of the
country
and what they had told us was that five
dollars was kind of the
the red line by which if you went above
that it would begin to serve as a
disadvantage
uh for people to seriously consider
taking up that product so
with that number in mind we've designed
this to
do everything possible to keep that
premium
below that threshold so that covers a
little bit on how to access the coverage
now let's talk a little bit about what
will be covered
so this plant provides sixty percent of
wage replacement for six weeks
the maximum duration of wage replacement
shall be six weeks per year
with no minimum duration required and if
you're
cj excuse me if you're following along
at home guys that's at the page at top
top of the page 33. thank you dj
thank you madam chairman um so
the things that will be covered let's
turn to that so the first
is the birth of a child or the care of
the newborn child within
one year of birth the placement with an
employee of a child for adoption or
foster care
and the care of the newly placed child
within one year of placement
caring for the employee spouse child or
parent
who has a serious health condition any
qualifying extingency
arising out of the fact that the
employee's spouse child or
parent is a covered military member
on covered active duty or caring for a
covered
service member with a serious injury or
illness
if the eligible employee is the service
member spouse
child parent or next of kin and finally
a serious health condition of the
employee
that isn't related to the employment to
their employment
and their employer does not offer
short-term disability insurance so
a couple of things as it pertains to
that last eligibility category
the first is obviously uh if the
reason for the leave is related to their
employment that's going to be covered
by their workman's compensation uh and
then the second piece
is around that that first person
coverage
and that was the the subject of some
discussion last year
a large portion of costs associated with
paid family medical leave are tied to
the
disability portion of the coverage
and the thought last year was that since
most new hampshire employers have
short-term disability benefits
the goal was to avoid cost that was
deemed to be
duplicative coverage and that being said
this was the source of some
passionate disagreement so to address
that concern
this plan includes first-person coverage
if their employer does not offer that
short-term disability insurance matt
again can you tell us the line in the
page for the short-term disability
insurance
matt that's the provision in the
independent the the business and
individual coverage
so this is page 37 line 24
okay that's good enough we'll get to
that later i'm just trying to make sure
we get all these references down
to time together thank you guys thank
both of you please dj continue
of course thank you madam chairman so to
conclude this discussion i'm
going to briefly touch on some of the
additional features
so the first is job protections so
individuals who work for an employer
with
20 or more employees will have job
protection
now here again there has been a bit of
discussion about whether that should be
50 employees which would mirror the
federal family medical leave act
or whether it should be some number
lower than that
the governor ultimately decided that the
number should be 20.
but that's obviously something that you
will have to consider whether that
you feel that that's the appropriate
number obviously um
more protection means the greater
likelihood that people will be motivated
to access
the coverage the more people in the pool
the better the premiums
second is through the rfi process
insurance carriers and
legislators have raised the issue that
the individual opt-in group may
experience
adverse selection this new plan revises
and tries to address those concerns in
several ways
the first is that there will be an open
enrollment period for individuals
in the opt-in group and that will be
limited to once a year
it will last approximately two months
the second is that the rating
will not be grouped with the state
employees or the other employers of the
state
and it will be based on the claims
experience of that particular group
and finally there will be a seven month
vestment period
to allow the program to become
capitalized
now i understand that some of these
features may not be
the most popular of this plan but if you
want to guard against
adverse selection and again ensure that
you are driving down those premium costs
to below five dollars per pay period
then from an insurance standpoint
this is how you'd approach it okay dj
i do have a question if i could
represent policeman
thanks madam chair is your mic on yes it
is good for you
i'm learning after about a couple okay
mary beth you're training us
so uh if we could back up you mentioned
the protections for
uh folks that are i guess
companies that have 20 or more
individuals what about the
20 the companies that employ less than
20 individuals
what kind of protections if any are
there for them
so there are no current protections in
terms of that that guarantee that the
individual will not
lose their job if they uh need to step
away
from their from their job uh for any of
the qualifying conditions
and what i would just add to that and
this is at the bottom of page 37
line 36 roman 3
employees of those companies that don't
qualify for the job protection elements
are have the opportunity to join the
individual purchasing pool
to receive those same benefits
so basically matt i'm not sure i
understand but
representative leishman asks what
happens if you don't work for somebody
who has 20
employees and your answer is there is an
individual protection
component that individuals in smaller
businesses could join if they chose to
do so is that correct
that's correct and that section begins
on page 36
and i apologize that we're jumping
around that's all right we pro
i'm making little notes i suppose
everybody else is representing leishman
do you have a follow-up
yeah thanks madam chair
so if an employee is disciplined or
faces some sort of action is fired what
state agency
would he go to to file a grievance
against the employer
for such a inaction by an employer
against that employee
so just so i understand the scenario
this
is an employee that participated in this
benefit
and was then fired because they took
right
pardon this benefit dj is that something
that that you could speak to this might
ultimately be decided through rules i
don't know that there's a specific
section of the legislation that
addresses that
um thanks matt so representative
leishman are you referring to an
individual who
if we were if you were to set that bar
at 20 or more employees and they were
they were terminated as a result of that
where they would go to have that
addressed yeah or if they learned that
they thought their employer was holding
money back or taking the five percent
a week for that benefit and then learned
that the employer was not putting that
money aside where would they go
to file such agreements i think it's
five dollars a week not five percent or
five
five dollars a week right well i
uh representative leachman i think uh it
could go a variety of places uh
commissioner of administrative services
will administer this program
uh but if an employer was charging a
premium
and not providing the benefit our
consumer protection
division here would have something to
say about that
okay but that's that's not in the bill
as of yet that's something you develop
later as far as rules is that your
understanding
or is that in rules that you have for
your agency overall
well it there isn't a rule specific to
this
to this potential fraud that would be
there but it
um but it is both
i i think in theory it's a violation of
our statute for charging in church
proving that you're not
provided the commissioner of ministry of
services is going to administer this
section
and so i assume uh they would be uh
appropriate to have rules there as well
thanks venom cheer okay please continue
madam chair i'm sorry i'm sorry
representative patcher i did not see
your hand up my apologies please ask
your question
when i chaired gel car i missed a lot of
hands myself um and thank you for that
my concern is exactly that rules
i often hear that that could be
addressed in rules um
having served on gelcar for a number of
terms having chaired that committee
i'm not sure that's what we need to hear
rules just that would be um
mandating the gel car legislates and
that is a
a big no-no so to speak
and if something's not laid out in a
bill
and it's not clear that that's the
legislative intent
for that activity to happen um under
541a um that's really not something that
goes forward in rules there has to be an
indicator
somewhere that that's the desire so to
expect
um and i'm sorry man i'm sure with the
lack of the better terms things that are
missed in the legislation
and this often does happen um and
expecting rules to address that
uh not a good plan and i'm not you can't
guarantee that that would be
addressing rules so my thought is it
needs to um
i guess there needs to be a further
explanation of representative
bleachman's question
other than it will be addressed in rules
thank you madam chief and representative
perhaps what i would say to that is if a
company is defrauding its employees
the state already has existing
mechanisms to address that
outside of any particular program and i
think to commissioner nicholas's point
those existing pathways would continue
to exist
so if i name adam chair follow-up paulo
thank you
well that that would be considered fraud
but um
with that you have to talk about intent
and all sorts of things
um there's a lot of things that it's
clear that uh
that there's protection there and and
i'm not a lawyer but i
uh we have lawyers on the committee i'm
not sure that's something that would be
captured under fraud thank you madam
chair
you know what i think what i could offer
is i i could have my team
put in a reference to our
insurance statute regarding charging
premiums and not providing a benefit
uh to make it clear i'll put that
together
to make it clear that we would have
authority uh
to assess administrative penalty and to
administer those claims could you do
that today
uh yes thank you if you could get that
to um me
and to lba nancy levines and michael
hoffman today electronically
or get that to matt and matt knows how
to get it to us so
we can do that representative walsh you
have your hand up for a question
do you have a question i do thank you
very much manager
so i want to go back a step and revisit
so if we've got
somebody say they have 20 or more
employees say somewhere between 20 and
and they is some sort of retaliation or
some sort of
problem that arises because of what the
employer is doing because somebody has
chosen to exercise their rights under
this
you suggested the department of
administrative services is where they go
there is no enforcement division there's
no
there's nothing within the department of
administrative services that i know of
that would allow them to have some sort
of
uh mechanism for protecting the workers
commissioner necopolis is from the
insurance department and i believe he
was referring to
his department not d.a.s
i think i think the job protection would
be equivalent to fmli
protection um that would be existing
just the same as any other um
a violation of fair medical leave
protection for those employees over 50
that currently exists so if
we're adding here a state provision that
says for
employers over 20 uh if they took
adverse action because someone
took the benefit of this coverage that
it would be
a state-based claim for a violation of
the family medical leave protection that
would not be administrative services
that would be a
thank you commissioner representative
walls what i might just add to that
the reference to das is that das is the
administrator of this program
as it pertains to the state so the das
would be charged with
soliciting uh proposals for this and
then administering the program i think
that's where the reference to
administrative services came from
they do administer other state employee
benefits
yes follow up man i'm sure i just wanted
to be clear i want to check with
commissioner nicolapolis and so what
you're suggesting is is if there's a
problem
that there is an a mechanism to enforce
fmla within the insurance department
uh uh representative law of
representative walls no
that that that would be uh it'd be a uh
i believe an eeoc claim initially and
then it would be a lawsuit for a
violation
just like any employer would access uh
access
but but if it's a state plan and you're
talking 20 to 50 you have another
follow-up
i do thank you does the eeoc have
jurisdiction on a state plan with 20 to
50 employees or where would that person
turn
that it did so that's they would be um
eeoc is the first step and then
ultimately the courts if
if they don't take it up would be
enforcing our state law the protection
uh that's where they would get that uh
authority
thank you commissioner representative
hatch do you have another question
i i do i apologize madam sheriff if i
may
um if somebody's disciplined or
dismissed for participating in this
program
um i'm not sure i understand
that representative leachman's answer
was questioned to retaliate against now
the scenario is the people are paid the
benefit
but the employer dismisses because they
have taken the benefit
and wants to either replace him or
whatever or feels that the
employee is being unjust and asking for
the benefit um
that's the protection that i'm i'm
wondering about
and what is your question representative
hatch
where is the protection for the person
it's not fraud if the
person's paid the family leave okay why
don't we let them go through the
sections we haven't we're still
kind of going through definitions i
think that's a good question let's go
through the sections we don't know that
yet we don't know what's in the plan at
all thank you madam chair and i
apologize for
uh jumping in thank you and i think some
of the confusion might be that
protection is being used in two
different senses
uh throughout this conversation but
let's let's go through starting the
topic page 31.
okay we're going gonna go through the
plan section by section
and then when we get done we'll know
whether we answered any of those
questions or not once we really
understand what's in here
thank you matt are you doing that now
yes so i i will take the lead on this
and
punt to dj uh where necessary but
lines four through 22 the policy and
purpose
that's what i tried to articulate to
begin this morning's testimony
it's fairly straightforward what we're
trying to accomplish here
through 12 on to the next page
are the definitions you see the
instances of when leave from work is
covered
dj previously spoke to those you also
see definitions
for serious health condition as covered
by the federal
i guess any questions on those first two
sections
specific questions on these two pages
represent walls
oh man i sure i just hadn't taken my
hand out i'm still trying
okay how the eeoc is going to enforce
state law because i don't okay we're
going to
turn the page to 33 please all right i
would just continue in the bottom half
of page 32 if i might
bottom of page 32 i rushed sorry
line 13 contracting administrative
authority
this directs the commissioner of
administrative services to solicit
information
for an rfp you see that section
continues
relative to the coverage that we've
previously defined
for those different categories
and matt i assume this language for the
contract and administrative authority is
consistent with the other language we
have given the das commissioner
for the other state benefits that he
does for us
yes this would be something that they
they've done in
other instances and and would be
familiar
on the top of page 33 and dj already
covered this as well
it is a 60 of the average weekly wage
with a maximum duration of six weeks per
year
uh subparagraph c
caps the amount of the benefit at the
which i believe is 133 000 or they're
about so
there is an upper bound to what this
benefit
uh lines six through 16
discuss the uh initial
uh phase-in if you will for employees
right so a 10-year requirement
in terms of months of work before
they're eligible
and then similarly a waiting period
which shall not be required element of
now on line 17 and through the next page
this talks about the
opportunity for the
public employees to leverage that for
private employees rights the the theory
of change here is that we will use the
state workforce that 10
000 person pool to help buy
down premiums in the private market that
we have a critical mass
that will make this coverage affordable
not only for the state
but also for those private employers and
their employees
that want to take advantage of this
benefit
you see the terms on line 32 33 and 34
that discuss a seven month wait waiting
period
a one-week elimination period and a
60-day annual open enrollment period
and that premium shall not exceed five
on to page 34
you have the conditions for private
employers
to establish a voluntary coverage
that non-state employers may choose to
provide fmli
at no cost to their employees or on a
contributory
or partially contributory basis again
this is what dj had discussed
that the private sector employers have
flexibility on how they would want to
extend this benefit
from there you see lines 11
through 21 discuss the procurement
process
and how the state would go about
selecting a private vendor to administer
this for state employees
22 through 32 discuss benefit
the discretion of the commissioner of
administrative services to modify
the initial benefit structure is within
his authority under this
and then on line 32 you see that the
fmli
advisory board is established
administratively attached to das
is a nine-member board that becomes an
oversight commission
to help resolve problems of the
procurement eligibility benefit design
on to page 35 now lines 11
through 18 discuss outreach initiatives
to continue
uh evangelizing the benefits of this
program and encouraging more private
employers
to take advantage there's a reporting
requirement
and also working in coordination with
the department of employment security
so i'll develop and implement that
outreach program that i was just
referring to
what is what do you see is the purpose
for the outreach
ultimately the larger this pool becomes
both in the private
and public sector the lower the premiums
will become
which is a benefit not only to the state
because the state is committing to
provide this coverage
but also to employees and their
employers in the private market
uh dj i don't know if there's anything
more on that point you'd like to add
i think you've summarized it perfectly
matt it's the
basics of risk pool 101 it's the same
principles that the state uses in
promoting the individual market
and you've summarized it very well the
the more people you have in that risk
pool
the lower your premiums will be well
while we have the mic i just wanted to
uh clarify the answer regarding where
they would uh
where they would file a claim regarding
a violation
of the 20 employee limit
i verify with a lawyer who does this
work just a second ago
and provided that we don't change the
definition of
discrimination in 354 a an employee
would not be required to go to eeoc
first they could they would be uh
eligible to
immediately file a superior court
lawsuit
for a violation of this protection
and it would be a state law based
uh claim and it would be a fast uh
access to the superior court
thank you commissioner i think
representative leishman has a question
on some of the pages we're going over
represent bleechman
yes i i do thanks madam chair but just a
comment for the commissioner i guess i'm
concerned that someone would be forced
to go to a superior court because
as you being a lawyer yourself know the
expense and sometimes
the delay that that would cause and
somebody in a situation that was
uh looking for this type of coverage
they have to file an action with
superior court
would seem somewhat onerous at least to
me but i do have a question matt
and staying as the chairs urged us to
uh by page this advisory board would
anybody be compensated those nine
members you're proposing
would there be compensation for them i
believe the only compensation
for that board would be legislative
mileage for the members of the
legislature that participate
what i would just go back to on your
concerns about
how someone would bring a claim to state
court
i would just like to stress that the
scenario in which
the question is going down assumes that
an employer
who is opting to provide a voluntary
benefit
to their employees right because we're
not mandating this coverage
this is a voluntary opt-in basis
why would an employer opt-in to this
program
only then to renege on that new benefit
they've established for their employees
i understand that that might happen
but i think you're concerned to be much
more warranted
if we were mandating this on small
businesses
and that just simply isn't the approach
we're taking here
if i could respond madam chair i think
you're probably missing my point that
the employer is collecting the five
dollars a week and for whatever reason
he keeps that money or
it doesn't get credited appropriate
that's my concern the protection
whether it's voluntary or mandatory
doesn't have any bearing it's
to make sure that that payment is
credited appropriately and the employer
is not
using the money for some other purpose
even though it'd be a small amount but
if they had 20 employees and they're all
participating
in time if the employer wasn't making
sure those payments were forthcoming
then
obviously the employee could be heard
and that's where i'm going and i
understand that concern
but again this would be something that
they would have to opt into
and those existing avenues would exist
for for something in that scenario
i don't think that's any more onerous
than if an employer was withholding
wages or not meeting
other existing guidelines under laws
under state or federal law
thanks manager okay please continue if
uh from there we're on page 35
you see the rule making authority in
line 26.
on line 28 is the appropriation and
funding transfer
this essentially is an accounting
mechanism for the administrative
services department to fund those costs
which are then further delineated on
line
31 sets a request for proposals to be
issued no later than september 30th
2021 we believe this gives das
sufficient time once the budget is
enacted
to proceed and issue a timely rfp
with the intent that this program is up
and running for state employees
by july 1st of 2022
that of course is the start of the next
fiscal year
right the second half of the biennium um
there is surely an opportunity to
accelerate that timeline depending on
how the rfp
process goes but the intent is that this
benefit
is in place for state employees within
the biennium
so madam chair as long as we're talking
about
the funds and appropriations and
transfers
a number of the bills matt we've seen on
this have had a
fixed figure i think of anywhere between
2.6 and more million dollars of general
funds to get started what are you
proposing as far as
as you mentioned general fund transfer
how much are you looking to transfer to
get this up and running general funds
so what i would say ultimately is that
this program
is going to be dictated based on the
rate that the state solicits during that
rfp
process that rate depending on private
market adoption
will continue to be driven down but to
walk through an absolute
worst case scenario where we're at that
five dollar threshold cap
if you look at the 10 000 state
employees give or take
times 52 weeks a year it's at most a two
million dollar hit
and that assumes this program does not
become
as successful and widely adopted in the
private market
but we think that given a healthy and
robust adoption
this becomes a de minimis benefit in
terms of costs to the state
and you'll notice that the funds from
the insurance premium tax which we'll
cover on page 36
are specifically allocated for that
purpose
so again we don't see this as a cost
driver for the state by any means
because even
the way we've structured this program is
that the more successful it gets and as
time goes on
the cost to the state will continue to
decrease so you're proposing
and we're just getting into line 35
section 70 and flipping the page that is
you're telling us that is non-general
funds
yes and that is the new language there
in subparagraph
c premiums written and authorized by the
insurance companies
are deposited into this premium
stabilization fund
which we'll cover here in the purchasing
pool
we don't usually transfer funds to an
agency to write
an rfp so if i can go back to
um i mean representative leishman and i
were thinking the same thing but he was
a few lines ahead of me i'm going to go
back to lines 31 33.
we don't usually do that i don't see
that we would need that das
rights rf rfps for
our medical coverage for our retiree
health
for a whole variety of things cyber
security
all kinds of insurance any insurance the
state has this is
they have a whole unit that does this so
i'm not sure we need those lines because
we do
fund them to do that
i i would just point out i think these
are different sections of the law so one
is detailing the program startup and
that's the
lines 31-34 that you were just
referencing yeah but it says
i must admit i think you're looking at
lines 28 to 23
30 you're correct i named the wrong
lines thank you matt
and then that would just be those those
startup costs for implementation right
they are that's why i'm saying das is
funded to do those things now
i don't believe that's tied to the rfp
issuance but i i would defer to
dj if he has a more specific answer or
we're happy to report back
in the alternative dj lines 28 to 30
what's the cost
yeah let me as matt said let me dig into
that further and let me make sure i'm
getting you the correct number
okay can you get that to me this
afternoon i can
we're only meeting until noon but then
we have to be
all day at the uh public hearing but i
will have a chance to check my emails
as we go along so i'd appreciate that
thank you sir and we'll bring
all that consolidated together into one
okay matt please continue i'm sorry i
made you go back a page but
no worries on page 36 you see the
new chapter chapter 282 dash b
the purchasing pool for a family of
medical leave insurance
this is a new section of the law so
again you'll see the
existing purpose the same definitions
that we've already reviewed
those are restated here
in an identical manner that brings us to
page 37
employer and employee rights and
responsibilities
and i think this is where most of our
conversation this morning is already
headed
to and i'll also spend a little bit of
time on this section so roman one
individuals who are employed by private
employers that do not
either family medical leave insurance
under this program
or a similar benefit with at least
equivalent coverage
have the opportunity to purchase that
coverage through the individual pool
right so this creates a mechanism that
whether or not your employer
opts in whether they are based on size
uh or just any other reason those
employees
are not caught out in the cold they have
an opportunity
to buy in through an individual market
that brings us to pay
29 and 30 the
end of line 28 the individual pool shall
operate by payroll deduction
a small business who opts not
but has two or three employees who
decide to join
and may or may not join the same program
for family leave because there is more
than
i think i know of three family leave
programs already operating in state
we've talked
about this before we've been talking
about family leave for years
you're requiring the little business
to make payroll deductions i mean a
little business doesn't make payroll
deductions for my car insurance
why wouldn't i pay that on my own
and i can help with that if you'd if
you'd like so the thought process
representative ober at the time was that
because these businesses
have the infrastructure in the systems
to collect
a variety of of taxes and
fees on behalf of their employees that
this could simply be slid into that same
infrastructure now that being said
um there are a number of different ways
that you could approach this potentially
if you wanted to put the onus
on the individual in a business of a
certain size or less
to pay the premium directly to the
insurer you could certainly
do that but this has been a topic of
conversation in the past
and for simplicity where the
conversation had landed at least as of
last year
was that because as i said there is some
familiarity
on behalf of the business to collect and
remit
uh things both to the state and federal
government that
this would not be an overly burdensome
ask
well small businesses disagree with you
dj i suspect
there is probably some varying opinion
yes ma'am yeah
a great deal of it i'm just bringing
that to your attention representative
i think you're muted oh you took your
hand down okay
oh i i took my hand down uh i was muted
thank you i'll get i'll get i'll
understand this eventually
okay please remember
no i i don't care i have my question oh
you do have a question
i'm sorry representative no i apologize
the onus is on me just back to this
employers
uh having the deduction i never had more
than 24 employees
this is not like you said dj this does
uh wouldn't be overly
overly cumbersome for me but i do have
concerns
um and i need to understand this better
and maybe there's a quick answer
i see that the most a individual can be
charged
is five dollars so if i have 24
employees
their uh premium is five dollars per
employee
i deduct that and i have my own
insurance but
i don't see anywhere in this bill that
doesn't allow insurance companies
to charge more than five dollars uh
per individuals and who's liable for
that
uh additional amount as an employer i
can only
deduct five dollars from them for this
program as a state
the same thing but nothing here
indicates
if the cost per individual is more than
five dollars per week and who pays the
difference
the employee care would i have to as an
employer
matt are you getting to that i
understand his question
yes well i apologize uh but i'm sure if
that wasn't an appropriate
question no that's an appropriate
question matt's looking through paper so
i think he's going to answer not dj
so this is on and dj please chime in as
well this is on page 33
lion 35 page 33
line 35 in response to represent
hatchet's question
which specifically deals with the
individual pool
which is related to what we're talking
about here
premiums for individual pool coverage
shall not exceed five dollars per
subscriber per week so
it's not a matter of who makes up the
difference we set
a statutory cap on what that premium
could be
and again we see that only as a worst
case scenario
where because we're leveraging the state
workforce
to contract with a vendor to provide
that benefit for 10
000 state employees and then allow the
private market to supplement that
we're going to continue to buy down
those premiums
at more and more competitive rates so
matt
let me tell you about a mistake i made
when i drafted the drug court
legislation years ago
i don't believe there are any mistakes
representative ober oh yeah
there was a an oversight if you will
and representative leishman was with me
when we did that
we had trouble getting that legislation
passed we did get the legislation passed
but we didn't give any thought to what
would happen
six years later seven years later eight
years later
when the cost of living has gone up and
the amount we authorized
really had no adjustment factor for
inflation
you have the same situation here five
dollars per week today
will not be the same as five dollars per
week
in eight years nine years how do we
adjust that and that's a concern i have
that you're going to get back to me on
because i don't expect you to have that
answer now but you're going to give it
some thought process
i i'm happy to provide additional
thought okay also say there are two
schools of thought about legislation
one is that it should take and act the
general court to
raise any dollar threshold period
others will index something to inflation
this bill would requ as written would
require the general court
to take an affirmative vote to change
that threshold
uh but i believe we would be amenable to
scaling it with inflation but that is a
i would say a policy determination for
the general court on how much authority
they would like to have on that cash
okay so representative hatcher's
question was which i don't think we've
asked
what happens if it's more does the
employer have to eat the difference
was that your did i restate your
question accurately
very well thank you madam chair and not
just the employer as well as the state
i think um i might be able to answer
this and i think representative hatch is
right
that the cap in the pool is to ensure
that the individual premiums paid by an
individual employee who decides to opt
in alone
is capped at five dollars this this lane
this bill in front of us
does not cap either the state's portion
or employers who opt in on their own
to that same five dollar cap so
commissioner you're pointing out the
line which we haven't really looked at
which is line 27 above that which is the
start of the paragraph that say
individuals who work for employers who
choose
not to offer fmla so you're saying this
applies to just that small group yeah
right and so it is it is
possible though i think a lot of work
has gone into to make sure that
these these these estimates are right it
is possible that
uh the state portion could be 5 and 25
cents
and uh the uh and when you factor in the
stabilization money to ensure that
individuals can get in
uh this bill does not yet or does not
include
a cap on what those kind of free market
charges will be
um there's a benefit design here um
that will allow companies to bid i
competitively bid
on on this product um the number could
come in
you know it could the situation could be
after we put this out to bid
that the five dollar cap is immaterial
because all the numbers are under that
okay but if we can focus on
representative hatcher's question
his question is he's a small business
owner running a business with 24 people
what happens if it goes up does he have
to eat it your answer
is if he has chosen to join
as a company this section does not apply
to him per se because it only applies to
companies where the business has
chosen not to join as a company is that
correct
i'd like to just to separate the two
potential
uh possibilities that were kind of
interwoven there okay but i'd like a yes
or no answer is that a yes or no answer
to represent patch's question
and he's not in his head yes as well
i'm going to give you two yes and no's
to the two scenarios that we talked
about
one uh if if representative hatch's
company opted to provide this coverage
to all its employees
uh and it was uh six we'll just say six
dollars
a week um he and his employees as a
benefit design he could decide whether
the company's paying for that or uh he's
sharing with the employees
and in that case that would be a
business decision that he makes
he could say we're going to opt in and
allow all the employees to join
and the benefit costs six dollars and
the company's not paying for it
uh and employees could opt to be in or
not so bill you could pay
all the money you could pay none of the
money and employees could pay
the six dollars so there's your answer
to your question
as a company and then the second answer
is if
uh if representative hatch opted not to
participate
and two of his employees opted to to
join through the individual market
those employees would be guaranteed
a premium under five dollars five
dollars would be the cap
uh and even if that coverage cost six
dollars because of the risk pool created
under this bill the risk pool would pay
the difference
but it does not go back to
representative hatch's company
as a small company 100
okay representative hatch i think we
finally answered your question
represent walls thank you madam chair
so i have a question here
let's say that we're collecting what
page and what line are you on please
uh it's a more broad question just
listen to my question you'll understand
please
and that is say that it it um
we're collecting five dollars per
employee and it turns out that
people are really taking advantage of
this and the the cost
to the state is closer to six or seven
dollars per employee
that is not what the bill says
representative walls that's what we've
just been going through
this line for five dollars per week
page 33 line 27
through line 35 is for individuals
who work for employers who choose
not to offer fmli it is capped at five
dollars
there is a line in here that we've
looked at on another page
that says employers may pay all
may pay none or may prorate with their
employees
so we're not saying that a company that
joins is capped at five dollars matt is
that correct
yes that is correct as written madam
chair you misunderstand where i'm trying
to go with my question
where i'm trying to go with my question
let's just for the moment confine it to
state employees
the state i mean it obviously the
questions applicable but for the moment
we're going to say just for the state
employees
let's say the state employees start
seriously taking advantage of this we
know 60
of our state employees over retirement
age they are at the age you start having
medical issues
so they start really taking advantage of
this and it ends up
costing more than the premium and it
ends up costing more than the pool
where does the money come from where
does the state
find the money to do this because it's
going to cost
more than we are collecting and that's
my question is
what is the burden on the state not what
is the burden on the employer
that is a question that is why we are
using
a private insurance company they will do
the risk
the state is not running its own
insurance agency
it's no different from my insurance
which comes from
a private company yours may come from
anthem yours may come from somebody
they have given us a cost for the year
based on what they see their risk pool
being
is that not correct commissioner it is
correct
uh but but uh representative wall's
question is a fair one
that uh it is possible that we go out to
bid
and the best bid twenty is six dollars
uh i think because the design here
uh is such that uh state employees
already have
uh some short-term coverage and so the
part of this
bill that's different for the state
employees and for
the private employers or for the
individuals is
that the first person coverage
is already covered by another state
benefit
that's covered by the state contract
already
and so um
that is going to um allow the
carriers that are bidding on this to
offset
the cost the state's portion of it is
actually going to be cheaper to deliver
than the group portion or the individual
portion um
and so and just to build on that
representative walls if you put that
cap of five dollars per pay per pay
week into a contract for state employees
what are the vendors going to do the
vendors are going to come in at the cap
more than likely because they're going
to guard themselves against
upward pressure on premiums uh but as
the commissioners described because
state employee benefits uh are far more
robust than
the average in the private sector that
is going to guard from
uh that that sky-high utilization that
you
uh posited in your scenario so let
follow up madam chair please
yes follow up thank you so let's move
then to the private sector that chooses
to participate those people with 20 to
50 employees
the same issue applies to them that you
know they're going to be capped
am i correct that they are also capped
at the 5 or no they can
they they may need to charge more is
what i'm saying you say
no only the only where individuals join
because their company
did not join only those people have the
cap
and so if those people join and it costs
more than the five dollars
and we exhaust the pool where does the
well representative walls what i would
say is there is a stabilization account
that is set up and we haven't quite got
there yet in the bill
um okay matt so why don't you continue
if you think we're going to get to an
answer that she's
that will answer that question certainly
uh roman 3 discusses employers with
fewer than 20 that wish to provide
coverage
have the opportunity to purchase that by
making remittances to the fund
essentially allows smaller companies
that want to provide this coverage an
avenue to do so
to benefit their employees that fund is
established on line four
of page 38 which is the fmli
premium fund established we make
remittances
the department of administrative
services is instructed to develop
student enrollment procedures
and it goes through to some of those
details there
on line 15 the premium stabilization
trust fund is established
this is the fund that i was just
referring to representative walls
that will help stabilize the individual
pool
um which is held separately and you see
that
again is derived from premium taxes
imposed on premiums written
and authorized by by duly authorized
insurance companies for fmli
insurance
madam chair yes so nobody has still
answered my questions yet
he's just getting to it let him go line
by line through this fund please
on page third matt just go line by line
through that
you said this would answer her question
you only got to the header
so on page 38 roman 2 which is line 25
says that the monies in this fund shall
constitute a
premium stabilization reserve and shall
be used exclusively for the purpose
of assuring that the premium charged two
participants
in the individual pool remain stable
from year to year
and do not exceed five dollars per
subscriber
per week do you believe that is what
answers her question i believe that is
what i'm trying to answer her question
with
to say that in the event that the
premiums are actually above five dollars
it's not a matter of who eats the cost
we've specifically developed a mechanism
to resolve that issue that's based on
premiums charged
for this type of coverage that will
stabilize that
over a period of years this is something
that dj referred to as similar
to how we deal with medicaid expansion
right to hold rates
more or less constant over time
and not have these wild fluctuations
based on who chose to take advantage of
benefits
or if you see swings and birth patterns
or things like that
this is designed to smooth that out
follow up represent walls
thank you and what if the cost exceeds
the fund
how's the cost exceeded the fund in the
medicaid expansion that we set up to do
this
i would have to defer to to dj or maybe
the commissioner okay
can somebody from the insurance agency
answer that question because
representative walls has a question
i don't know the answer to that to the
fund question
um but the rates that will be
uh assessed on the state and on uh the
voluntary group participants
will be set sufficient to offset
um the individual participants who join
and the five dollar cap
now with like any insurance the beauty
of this product
is we're asking a company who's in the
business
of using actuaries to determine what
appropriate rates
are to create this product for us and to
bid it
understanding the framework that we're
establishing in this or
there are established in this bill
in a if a company bids for this and has
the product
they are they are required to uh to
offer it at five dollars for the
individual
and for the members who participate and
if in a given year
they have good performance or bad
performance that's going to impact the
following year's
rates um but that that's the business of
insurance
and and the stabilization fund should
allow for some flexibility in making
sure that the
swings are less but i think
compared to a option where fmli
insurance is provided by the state and
all of the downside was going to be on
the state which we've seen in previous
years
this product allows a a business an
insurance company
to do that for us okay representative
walls i don't know if that answered your
question or not
do you have a follow-up i do please so
let me go back to the state employees
what if the cost on the state employees
even with your
short-term disability insurance exceeds
what we're bringing in in premiums
so we're using an rfp process to
establish a rate
and at that point that would be dictated
by the terms of the winning bidders
contract with the state right they are
they are agreeing to provide a service
at a certain cost
if their actuaries don't accurately
compute the cost
i believe that's something that would i
mean the risk is transferred at that
point to the bidder
right that you are responding to an rfp
to administer a certain program for a
certain cost
and again i don't know that this is
something
that that we're trying to get into and i
guess the other thing is that
this provision isn't all that different
this particular provision isn't all that
different than senate bill 1
which was vetoed two years ago for
because it was an income tax
but i don't remember these same
considerations being
raised specifically on sb1 which had a
mechanism more or less identical to this
well i i was not on that for sp1 but
follow okay
let's continue like we don't really have
time to
figure a point do you have a specific
question
representative leishman what i'm trying
to do is if the plan
say that the bid comes in say we're
charging for state employees five
dollars per person
i keep telling you that the plan for
five dollars a person
is very clearly delineated on that page
for individuals whose employer
employer does not opt to join the plan
the state employees the state as an
employer is
opting they have then per the lines we
have read
the option to charge the full premium to
the
employee who may opt out
to pay all the premium of to the
employee
who may opt out or who to to charge them
a parcel premium
in addition per the lines we've read
if you offer short-term disability which
the state does short-term disability
takes over before this does so we're not
charging the state employees a
five dollar cap that is not what the
bill says
representative leishman you have a
question thanks man of chair
just like to say i do agree with matt on
one thing
if an insurance company does sign a
contract with the state they'll be
obligated to meet
the terms of that contract so which
leads me to my question madam chair
when mr bettencourt appeared before us
to present the governor's plan about two
years ago you said that you had reached
out
with a number of requests for
information to determine if there was
interest by a number of different
insurance
carriers to the five dollars and i don't
think we ever heard back
whether we get favorable comments back
because obviously an rfp was never put
out but
requests for information uh how did that
turn out did you have a lot of interest
were they supportive of this five dollar
proposed premium
i thank you representative leishman uh
you are correct that
um we have relied heavily on a lot of
the information that we got back from
that
rfi in terms of
interest overall there was a great deal
of interest for
this type of approach don't quote me on
this but i want to say that we got
responses back from approximately eight
to ten
insurers who expressed interest they
provided the state with some
advice and some feedback a lot of that
advice and feedback
centered around adverse selection which
gave rise to the provisions that i
highlighted earlier that addressed that
problem
the question as it pertained to the five
dollar per pay period
cap or threshold was not raised with the
insurers
as i mentioned before where that came
from the
the genesis if you will of that came
from
uh advocates of paid family leave who
had done research and who had done work
in other states
and had identified that as the threshold
by which you would not become overly
burdensome financially for people to
access that coverage
uh thank you thanks madam chair matt
please continue
i believe we are on page 38
line 25 roman 2. i believe that's what
we had just covered
yes uh again you see similar language on
the reporting and outreach that we've
already detailed
and again the theory there is that more
participants will drive down premiums
for everyone
the other thing that i would say
especially for whoever does
win that contract with the state through
this rfp
they have a first mover advantage that
unsuccessful bidders would not have
right because now they've already
established
a large pool and that will help that
provider provide lower rates in the
private market
so there are benefits to dj's point as
to ultimately
you know being the sole provider of the
state under that rfp
you see the rule making authority again
delineated here
the appropriation and funding transfer
and again this is for the individual
pool
this section here there is one technical
correction just to align
this january 1st 2022 date with the july
1st
2022 date that i already specifically
referred to
that started the fiscal year we would
want those dates to be
aligned and i apologize so what should
that july 1
and i'm happy to bring that as an
section 72 of the bill that's page 39
line 18
discusses discrimination in the
workplace and this is
specifically what we were talking about
with the job protection provisions
so if the company opts in and is larger
than 20
there are job restoration provisions at
the
end of that period of leave
and this here is consistent with the
provisions of the federal
fmla or federal family medical leave act
are there any questions on job
protection i know the earlier
conversation did focus on that quite a
bit
representative bleechman did you ask
that
i believe thank you i was just writing
down some of my
thoughts here but i think the
commissioner of insurance said that he
was going to provide us with some kind
of protection language yes he did
um today later yeah so that
that's what i'm looking for okay matt
brings us
to section 73 at the bottom of this page
uh just again an exception for the this
premium fund that we've established here
amending an existing rsa by adding a new
subparagraph
similarly for the premium stabilization
trust fund
which brings us to section 74 which is
the last section of this
portion of hb2 which details the 50
percent
of premiums can be held against the
business enterprise tax as
credit uh for the taxable period which
the premium is paid
and again we see this as a further
incentive for small and mid-sized
businesses to reduce their liability
while simultaneously providing this
benefit to their employees
and the businesses have a wide degree of
latitude on how those benefits are paid
for
either by themselves by the employees or
in some prorated fashion
representative hatch thank you madam
chair and this i mean
um probably goes along with some of
representative walsh's questions
have you um estimated what the magnitude
of that fund will be
and um in other words is there do you
anticipate
after a year 50 participation or uh i
mean you just
must have some uh performers um
made out and i i would just like to get
a sense of the size of that
fund and what's your anticipation and
representative hatch when you say fund
are you talking about the the tax
credits that are held or are we talking
about the premium stabilization
trust medium state stabilization tax
credits are
that are held in your entirety so you're
talking about
uh section 74 line 3 page 40.
yes i am thank you matt i
so i believe we're conflating two
separate things
here so there is a premium
stabilization trust fund which is funded
based
on a percentage of the premium insurance
tax specific to these types of
policies right separately and i
would draw a bright red line here
businesses that opt in
can claim a debt tax credit
against their taxable obligation and my
question first is with that thank you
so your question is about the bet tax
credit right
what the magnitude of that uh will be
yes and just to clarify that these
monies do not go to the premium
stabilization trust fund
we did reach out
no no worries we did work with dra and i
don't know if anyone from dra is on the
line to explain their fiscal analysis
but ultimately
if the cra's on their line would you
raise your hand
they did determine that it was
indeterminable at this point
um it depends on the adoption so we we
do not have a specific
dollar amount to to cite but dra has
been
part of these conversations and i don't
know if um
it looks like carolyn lear from dra is
on
carolyn are you an attendee and if so
high representative um someone just uh
gave me speaking yes yes we i couldn't
find you so i thank nancy or mike
whoever did that
um i don't have uh anything to add matt
has it exactly right we don't have the
data that would be necessary to
analyze the potential fiscal impact of
this
bet credit because it is entirely
related to the uptake rate
for the program
thank you so much representative hatch
do you have a follow-up
yes i do i i we have some people that
are pretty good in math
so what's your as i mean when you do a
urfp there has to be some
information as to the potential for
participation
do you have any of those numbers i
probably could carry the cost to the
bet well i guess as far as the fiscal
impact
given that this program is not
operational until the second year of the
biennium
you would it would apply to oh i should
defer to dra here but the taxable
periods for which this
would be this credit would be eligible
for would only be taxable periods ending
on or after july 1st 2024
she's muted she's unmuted uh
i think you you have that correct um and
likely the fiscal impact for tax
purposes
would not fall in 2023 at all
because i think it's unlikely that a
business would modify their estimated
tax
payments during the tax year to account
for what is probably a very small
proportion of their overall liability
um so i don't think you would expect to
see the impact in 2023 at all
um thank you and just how many people do
you
expecting uh participating in this or do
you have that number
the first year and second year
i can see if we can work to similar
adoption rates
um either for for similar programs but
again anything that we would provide
would be a stab in the dark but what i
would just say is
as more people join this pool the lower
the premiums would be so we do expect
this to accelerate
um the longer that it goes but
as far as that initial uptake
that is a very haphazard guess at this
point
matt i do have a couple of questions
that
i can't tell you i generated i actually
as i indicated have had a lot of
comments and some of these came from the
new hampshire retail association who
actually
indicated they're very excited about
this
optional opt-in plan one of the
if the employer opts in
in retail not every employee
however i don't know how many retailers
pay weekly as opposed to bi-weekly or
once a month
but should you have a retailer who pays
weekly and you have an employee who
doesn't work in that week
but who's opted in aren't there
provisions that you are not allowed to
double take a weekly price
premium out of somebody's pay if they
one week they work one week they don't
so i i don't know if i'm the best person
to speak to this but
the benefit is there is 60
of their average weekly wage so
you i suppose if you're a business in
that type of an environment where some
employees work
in some weeks but not others you would
probably want to extend that
but okay i'm sorry i didn't work my
question well my fault not yours you
answered a question i should have asked
i didn't um i'm a small
retailer i opt but i have more than 20
employees so i do
opt in but i do charge my employees part
of the premium or maybe all the premium
i don't know
but i have employees who don't work
every week i pay weekly
how do i get that weekly premium
deducted i see with this scenario so
in this instance the
weekly paycheck would be negative
is is the concern right that if i make a
hundred dollars in one week and i'm
charged two dollars for this benefit
i don't work the next week i'm charged
another two dollars
yes in theory i owe you two dollars that
uh
i don't know that this bill specifically
addresses that concern i think we'd be
open to clarifying that
um to the extent that that is a nascent
concern
um but i i would defer to someone that's
better steeped in employment law than
myself though
okay um then someplace in here there's a
it refers to equivalent
plans being offered by employers and i
know there are some employers in my area
who are offering family leave already
but they opt to offer something like say
four weeks at 100 pay not six weeks at
60 or whatever is that equivalent how do
you define
equivalent i would turn that to the
department
if if i might well i'd be happy to
return
commissioner or dj the equivalent would
be
at least the same coverage outlined in
the plan
and so it would have to be at least six
weeks
it would have to be both uh first party
and
second party family coverage uh i think
if it
exceeded the benefit that would be fine
i don't know that
there's any ability to call it
equivalent if it didn't meet the
minimums outlined in but if they paid
more commissioner
than what this plan pays for a shorter
period
why wouldn't that be equivalent
let's say i make a hundred i make a
hundred dollars a week because i have a
very simple mind
so in six weeks
i'm going to get 240 dollars
60 a week is 60 60 60 60 right
360. 360. but four weeks at 100
and what i would just say madam chairs
if if we could go back to that specific
i don't want a big career if we just
came out and i got thinking about it
yeah no and that's a very good question
right because that's something that
ultimately we want employees to receive
the the maximum benefits they can offer
i'm just curious how the existing
language would interact
or where that equivalency provision
arises
i'm not sure i thought someplace you
said it so maybe it was opening
statements
no no i know it is in the bill i just
i'm curious when
that matter of equivalency ultimately
comes into play
i believe it's for the individual pool
and if you're an employee you would in
that case
choose the economic decision to not join
the individual pool but continue
with your company's plan given that okay
so that would be
individuals only if my company didn't
opt in am i confusing
those two i just don't remember what you
said it
flashed across my brain when somebody
and i'm looking for that section as well
i'm trying to okay in the meantime you
look
maybe representative walls has a
question that the commissioner can
answer or dj
why you look for mine representative
walls
i have two different areas i want to
address both of which deal with money
appropriately
one is if we turn to page 30 we can't
hear you
okay i'll speak up one or better if we
turn to page 35
and we go to lines 22
22 it says that the department should
develop and implement an outreach
program to ensure
basically that people are made aware of
the program that's what that says
that presumably is going to cost money
my question is where does that money
come from
das is currently budgeted for that in
their insurance and risk department
they do outreaches on all of the
employee benefits now including retiree
health which has a worldwide
impact so that is part of the duties we
funded
in das and that duty is shared with the
department of employment security as
well
okay i just want to make sure the
money's there no i
good question but we did fund it okay
my second one actually has to go back to
the state
insurance premiums so have we if it's
gonna cost about two million dollars
what page are we on now please um
i don't have the exact page but i'm not
sure i need to
if the state has to pay for the state
insurance premiums for the state
employees
do have we budgeted that money
is there a statement in here that says
the state must pay for all the insurance
premiums for this probe
program so i believe das would be
working on a fiscal note but ultimately
that fiscal impact is indeterminable
based on the rate the state will solicit
during that rfp
we calculate and giving that that five
dollar
number that that's specified in the bill
right if that's the intent to solicit
below five dollars
per subscriber per week the maximum
impact to the state
would be two million dollars and we
suspect that it will be below that
and continue to fall as more private
sector
companies uh go through that adoption
so it's an indeterminable amount but it
is
no more based on what we've laid out
than two million dollars
follow-up represent walls yes where does
that two million come from where is that
budgeted
so that would need to be accounted for
from das implementing this program and
as we always do with salary and benefits
we do see lapses throughout the year
so that would have been factored into
our more conservative
than previously estimated lapse figures
that are contained
in the governor's executive budget
summary and that is because this
is indeterminable only the second year
the biennium
that's correct so this benefit would
only be for the second year the biennium
and as always we see lapses out of class
10 class 11
class 60 and as a result that
would be accounted for through lapses so
you took
a more aggressive lapse when you did
your budget
a less aggressive lapse a less
aggressive lapse so you're
allocating because you took a less
aggressive lapse if i get this my head
around this again i have a simple head
you took a less aggressive lapse so
there would actually be
a bigger lapse and you're expecting that
that could cover
the second year of the insurance did i
hear that correctly
you did hear that correct representative
in turning to the governor's executive
budget summary if you look at the
surplus statement
like i can find that with all these
papers now matt i mean have fun
hello on page 16 you see
governor's recommended lapses of 92
million in fy 23.
you see that fiscal 21 were projected
for 150 million
you see in fiscal 19 that our lapses
were 147 million
so this is a conservative budget that's
built intentionally
um and we're more than comfortable uh
with the lapse figures even when
accounting for this additional benefit
do you know how many state employees we
have met i believe we have roughly 10
hired and i think 11 000 and change
authorized positions oh we've been
grab reserve walls i'm sure i presume
there's a cost to develop the
state pool um and
i'm trying to figure out where that
money is okay what page you're on now
please
um well let me go back to the pool here
hang on
i i you know i'm having a hard time
wherever the state pool is here yeah me
too that's why i was asking you the page
number we're flipping through a lot of
pages matt do you know the page
number for that uh i don't i i i can
it is a little cold for a swim today
not the trust fund but a pool mary beth
line 39 page i'm sorry page 39 line
page 39 line 12 to 14
12 to 14. this is a funding transfer and
then below
on 15 to 17 the implementation of the
individual pool
so are you talking about the individual
pool
i'm just trying to figure out so it
could be so 15 to 17 man
yeah 39
39 lines 15 to
17.
so that would be the individual pool for
employees whose employers do not
and the question is where does the money
come from
i think i might be able to answer that
matt um there
there shouldn't be any money to
administer that pool
the insurance carrier who's opting to
provide this coverage
is doing that as a individual insurance
obligation to those
members
and so it's the pool are the folks that
are
opting to be in individually um
and and so i don't the state's not going
to be administering that
thank you but
mandatory says the state treasurer shall
transfer funds
that is or go ahead no that's a that's
another line above that's not related to
that's 2282 b colon8
we are talking about the pool in 282 b
okay well let me go back to colon eight
where does the money come from
this would be the general fund impact
for the state to provide the benefit to
the employees this is a provision that
allows
the treasurer to transfer money to das
for this purpose
employment testified that was 15
commissioner i can never say his last
name
nicholas yeah perfect
another good greek yes we did have that
testimony
they were by the way favorably um
leaning towards this yes and we've had
extensive conversations with
uh both uh the commissioner and deputy
commissioner at flavors
yes they were both on with us last week
madam chair follow up repeat
so i you know i agree the administration
is small but the implementation that
could be three million dollars initially
and 1.6 million a year by the numbers
that i've come up with
and that's where i'm asking where that
comes from
we don't know where you're getting three
million dollars and we're using a
we're not doing it in-house it is not a
state insurance
it's not a state-run insurance program
we are going to partner with the private
sector
and a well-established insurance company
that does this for a living
so am i to understand that there's no
hit to the general fund on the cost of
this program
except for potent an indeterminate cost
for the part that employs to the state
employees
so the cost would be to provide the
benefit to the extent in which state
employees
take it and again that is something that
will be dictated based on the contract
of the rfp
and then the amount the state
chooses to contribute to that as opposed
to asking the
employees to pay which we could pay
so the the envision here is that it's
benefit provided to
the state workforce by the state as
written
so private in private employers have the
option
to pay or prorate and we're going to put
state employers in it
state employees and yes the state would
cover their state employees thank you
matt
yeah follow up follow up
so those numbers came from the fiscal
note on the family medical leave from
two years ago because that's what the
actuarial people
projected that was actually the fiscal
note
two years ago was something close to
hiring
42 new employees over at department of
employment security
plus programmers to write the software
for the state to run an insurance
program
we are not running an insurance program
we are partnering it out 43 million was
43 employed
representative leishman says i misquoted
the either the amount or the number of
employees we were going to hire
so that fiscal note doesn't apply
because it's a different thing that had
the state doing
everything this has the state using a
private insurance company
okay well it was also in the governor's
bill 730 last year
so if you look at the fiscal note for
that
[Music]
i would defer to dj on that if i might i
wasn't in this role two years ago i
haven't had a chance to review that
specific well
number one i haven't looked at this plan
vis-a-vis
the two years ago one specifically i
um i don't know as how they are exactly
the same we're dealing with this plan
and we're asking questions on this plan
please but i'm also talking about the
governor's plan this was the second one
i'm referring to was 7 30 which is we're
dealing with this year's governor's plan
not whatever was in the building two
years ago i did not ask dj and matt to
bring a comparison
between the two plans to see the changes
we're dealing with what's in front of us
only
we didn't pass last year's i agree but
since
we don't have a fiscal note that's why i
was going back to that trying to pull up
some numbers
so that was why i referenced that
because we didn't have the fiscal note
here
and if if it is similar das would be
instructed to do a similar fiscal note
and i
i don't know the status of that but um
i i can't speak to that okay
madam chair if i could i think you know
the impact of this particular plan and i
believe
all of us support the program or the
concept of the program but
i'd certainly like to see a tightening
up of the numbers because if you just do
the 10 000
state employees i think that works out
to about 2.6 million dollars
as you said we're looking at at least a
two million dollar hit
to quote you but i'd like to see the
numbers tightened up because one of the
things the chair may recall
in some of the other or one of the other
plans it may have been
7-12 the
proposal was that the general funds
would be returned through like a loan
process or the loan general funds were
loaned to the
program and then they'd be returned yes
that was part of last year when we were
going to run the insurance program
yeah so if we could at least get a
better number we're not doing that
well and again the maximum impact that
we would project
would be 10 000 state employees times 52
weeks in a year times that five dollar
threshold that we've set that would get
you
at most 2.6 million
2.6 and again we fully expect to have an
rfp that comes in below that price point
that will then be compounded by the
private market continuing to
broaden that risk pool and again the
cost to administer this to the state
will decrease as time goes on
and as the program is adopted by more
private entities
thanks madam chair thanks matt matt and
dj
we thank you for being with us and
listening to our
maybe hundreds of questions
representative emerick do you have the
last question for the morning
hi yes thank you madam chair and i don't
know who i'm asking the question of
who's going to determine whether a
company is bought into this
or it's three employees in a company
that didn't buy into it
but is remitting a check the companies
that buy into it are remitting a check
the companies that didn't buy into it
are remitting a check
how are we going to know the difference
why do we need to know the difference
because if the company didn't buy in the
employees can get it for five bucks
if they did buy in it could cost them
750.
it'll it'll be driven by the um
the application at employer or
individual level
so once this program is rolled out a
company is going to be opt
have the option to opt in for their
employees and if they do they'll fill
out their paperwork it'll be rated based
on on their risk profile
uh or they won't opt in and the
employees will have the right to do it
on their own
um and so it's it's it'll be it'll be
treated no different than employers who
offer
other uh benefit uh access to other
benefit insurance products
you know an aflac is something you might
be able to relate that to your employer
may offer you access to
uh products and so thank you so i guess
the answers are going to ask them
yeah so representative emerick says that
answers the question
i think i have a potential resolution to
your issue with section
one in hb2 that i want to discuss with
the group
i want to take however a short 10 minute
break we have all been sitting
in our chairs for two hours
so if tracy is going to mute the room i
would ask the participants at home
to mute and block your screens we'll be
back at approximately
four minutes before eleven
thank you everybody for participating
thank you for coming
and we are going to be in recess for 10
minutes thank you
i have one more question we are in
back matt is still with us
matt is a new member of division one
um don't tell division two
i won't tell division two when we were
leaving
representative walls had a question
represent walls are we live
tracy are we represent walls do you
still have a question
um i actually called commissioner
nicholapolis
on the break and he did address it so
okay
i will tell you that but however there's
something going on here where i can it
says you cannot start your video because
the host stopped it
uh nancy and mike are weak yeah it's
back
somebody okay you're back sorry i didn't
do anything it's magical
uh i know but i just thought i'd mention
that that um
so yeah yeah i spent the break on the
phone with the commissioner so okay
matt we have the rainy day stabilization
fund which is
yet another of your sections in hb2
can you tell me what page you're on and
what section it is because we were going
to talk about that
so we're on page 40 this is section 77
okay page 40 section 77 this is lines 20
to 25 and this is
uh hopefully a much briefer conversation
than the last one but i'm happy to
answer any questions that may arise
uh the intent here and it's just a
one-word change
that changes the the cap of the revenue
stabilization reserve account or the
rainy day
fund to an amount equal to 10 percent
of unrestricted general fund revenue
over the biennium
currently our cap is 10 of a single
fiscal year
and the impetus behind this change
really does speak to
the revenue shortfall we forecasted at
the beginning
of this pandemic we felt that this cap
was overly restrictive
for a type of event that absent what
turned out to be a robust
recovery uh the state would have been in
a very difficult spot
so this does not automatically require
the state to put any additional
funds into the rainy day fund but rather
allows us
to put essentially up to 320 million
there
if we ever were to so choose the current
statute limits us at roughly 160 million
which means we're almost full given that
we're at 115 million dollars today
why would we want to do this i think the
biggest thing
to highlight is that when it comes to
managing through a crisis
the state should have sufficient
reserves to
make sure that we're able to to steer
through it we budget on a biennial basis
we think it makes sense to tie the rainy
day fund to a biennial basis as well
separately this does impact our bond
rating and i do have a report from pew
charitable trusts that i will share with
the committee
digitally as well but new hampshire's
bond ratings are very strong
some of the strongest of any state in
the country but what i would say
is that and this report does detail it
there's opportunity for the state uh
jerry can you get that report
and matt do you have it digitally
to either quickly zip to
michael caine or or michael hoffman or
nancy
so that the people can see it at home
absolutely
i'll send that as soon as we conclude
here but essentially that
it's not a function of what percentage
of the rainy day
cap is funded but rather how much money
the state has this is one copy right
this is one copy um i am going to have
janet clayman make copies of this for
everybody and
email and snail mail it out to mary beth
and bill we haven't seen it either
but we will get electronic copies for i
mean hard copies for those of us sitting
here
mary beth and bill you will get a copy
of this in the mail
afterwards best i can do at the moment
and i i can email the link online as
well
great thank you
yes i just have a quick simple question
what does it do to our bond rating does
it raise it or lower it how does that i
think that's what he's about to tell us
and we just don't have copies of them so
so the benefit of course is bond ratings
are assessed based on how well the state
is prepared for an adverse financial
impact
anything that the state can do to better
prepare
itself such as putting a higher cap on
the rainy day fund
and allowing us to accrue more money
there and if you think back to two years
ago
when we had a such a robust surplus we
were trying to find
one-time projects to spend it it would
have been fortuitous to maybe put
a bit more of that into the rainy day
fund for the
a potential crisis this would simply
offer that additional flexibility to the
legislature
to put additional money in the rainy day
fund it doesn't require anything
to go there so your answer is this would
strengthen our bond rating in response
to represent wallace's question what
does it do to our bond rating is that
correct
correct but it would it would it doesn't
directly do that because the state would
have to actually
put money there to see those benefits
but allows
additional flexibility for the state to
do so and if the state were to do that
it would likely have a positive impact
on follow-up representative walls
no i think he just answered my question
and that is raising the rating doesn't
i'm sorry raising the cap doesn't change
the bond rating it's if we fully fund it
that changes the bond rating
correct and there's not a magic number
or a percentage right it's a holistic
review of the state's finances
but being better prepared for an
economic downturn
would have some positive impact it may
be de minimis given that we're already
on the upper end
of those ranges compared to other states
new hampshire is
very strongly rated by all three rating
agencies
s p moody's and fitch but again this is
just a good management structure that
would allow us to steer through a crisis
if coven had not rebound or the the
large multinational companies that have
continued to pay our business taxes
predominantly um hadn't rebounded as
robustly
as they have okay sure but wouldn't it
then lower our borrowing costs
if we fund this doesn't it then lowering
our borrowing costs for everything we do
if our bond rating improved whether for
this factor or any other factor
as part of a good management of state
finances yes that that would have that
but i i will say that the returns may be
de minimis
given that we're already on the upper
tier of that range
thank you please continue
all right deb you said anything
everything you want that's all i have
again this really just aligns the rainy
day fund with our biennial budget is the
biggest takeaway representative leachman
i only have one question madam chair
would you accept a motion to approve
i would representative leashman
representative leishman moves to approve
on the motion to approve section
77 the revenue stabilization cap
in hb2 if you're in favor of the motion
when your name is called
please say yes if you're opposed please
say no represent vembrick is going to
call the role for us what we know about
representative burge
is he got a second shot yesterday
we don't know if he's having a reaction
or sleeping or what because
he intended to be here we did try to
call him
we got no response we did text him we've
got no response so we're hoping
that his second shot has just made him
sleepy
and he's not had a car accident on his
way in or something critical but we've
heard nothing bad
so we're hoping for the best so
representative emerick when you're
ready to call the role
yes
okay so far three episode voted yes
rep i voted yes represent griffin voted
yes
uh representative emerick just turned on
his microphone
we're slow to be trained but we're
learning representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes representative
walls
yes man i'm sure the vote is
six to zero vote is six to zero matt
thank you for coming with it we are not
doing anything with family leave this
morning
you gave us a lot to think about but it
is not something we're going to do at
this time
i would like to have the committee turn
to section
all right section 55 is the distribution
of
rooms and meals and as you know from
previous conversation
mrs lavinas researched this
extensively and found out
how complicated it was and how deep it
was this has been in hb2
for every i think
all the eight years i've done budgets in
house finance
the final result was mrs lavina's
thought and i agree with her
we should leave it in it is much too
complicated
probably requires a policy bill to make
a change and i'd like to
welcome representative wyler who is
going to sit in with us for
the rest of the morning it's nice to see
you sir and there's a microphone right
there
to turn on we're just about to vote in
the distribution of rooms and meals tax
which is the section that's been in hp2
for a number of bienniums and i would
move to
approve this section section number
please
representative emerick seconds on the
motion to approve section
55 in hb2
if you're in favor you'll say yay when
your name is called if you are
yes i'm a yes
representative wyler yes representative
griffin
yes representative
yes representative hatch um
yes madam sheriff i'm just comment after
the voting thank you
representative walls yes
representative patch i think you stuck
your hand up and i did not see it
on my sincere apologies not necessarily
i certainly understand
i just wanted to note that um rooms and
meals
um the hospitality industry is vitally
important to this state
yes that mechanism to fund
um the promotion of that activity um
through a portion of the rooms and meals
tax um
was was great and very effective
and and i'm just though i voted yes i
i had to really contemplate this pretty
hard
um and my first inclination was not to
vote yes
particularly where we're reducing the
amount of the wounds and meals tax and i
and i just my concern is that it's very
counterproductive but
in the sense of cooperation i voted yes
and
hopefully we can address this in the
future and bring it back as soon as
possible
thank you madam chair for your
indulgence okay
i i don't think we reduce the amount of
rooms and meals tax
this section says the provisions of
rsa-12011b
creating a portion of meals and rooms
tax revenue
to the division of tribal and tourism
development are hereby suspended for the
biennium ending
june 30th 2023 i think the intention was
not to reduce but if they got more
especially given the pandemic
when rooms and meals tax has been lower
that they could
support that industry and i couldn't
agree more with you
that that industry is vital to us
represent hatch
[Music]
thank you madam chair all right we have
two amendments and i have to
credit the diligence of represent walls
to start
them could lba bring up on the screen
the shea farm amendment for the
department of corrections
gentlemen madam chair
yes given that your amendment apparently
is broader than mine would it make sense
for me to withdraw my amendment
and just use yours i got them in two
pieces so we could use them both
the next one is the second transitional
housing
so yours is only one unit and mine's
only one unit is that yes
they had already started on yours by the
time i worked this out with helen
in the afternoon so we left it
with yours and added mine so you'll see
a second amendment very shortly
so this this division was
all of us a bit distraught about
the cuts to department of corrections
we've restored
vocational training and education this
would restore the cuts to transitional
housing
shea farm i'd like to thank
representative walls for
pushing that this might not have
happened had she not done that last
thursday
so represent walls might i assume you
would move
to approve this amendment
you most definitely may assume that
madam chair
okay representative hatch seconds that
motion thank you madam chair thank you
both
so on the motion to restore the funding
for shea farm
if you are in favor when your name is
called please say yes if you are opposed
please say no
madam chair would you like me to speak
to the amendment briefly first um
yeah sure you could all right so what i
did with this is we had to find money so
i pulled the money out of the budget for
the courts
and there were that's not going to
happen
i funded both of them without
all right then i'm going to be quiet
okay
representative yes i'm a yes
representative weiler
yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yes representative walls yes
i don't share the vote of 7-0
the vote is seven to zero
and lba if you can bring up
the second transitional housing
amendment
with the second amendment we will
fully restore the funding to docs
and this goes along with the shea farm
and basically so you know how we funded
it
i talked to representative berger she
was going to make
a cut in
hb2 that gave us enough money to fund
both of these still meet our cut goal
and still restore both of these and
i actually started working on that
friday because of the push by
representative walsh
and i knew she was working on it because
i'd asked her to
and then in the afternoon when helen
sent me this
i called karen we had a conversation we
have the money to fund it
the addition of transitional housing in
manchester
and to approve the doc budget
with the completion of this we will have
another budget done is there a second
representative emerick seconds if you're
in favor of approving the amendment
to restore the housing to manchester
transitional housing and to approve the
doc
budget you will say yes when your name
is called you will say no if you're not
represent leashman comment
yes thanks man of chair and i know i
speak for all my colleagues on both
sides that we really appreciate your
efforts on this and
it has not gone unnoticed thanks thank
you
madam chair yes i'd like to second that
but i also have a technical question and
that is given that we just approved my
amendment
and i honestly don't understand how
these work this is a true legitimate
question
given that i had indicated to do a back
of the budget cut to
the judiciary and we're now approving
this with
a separate cut in hb2 how does that work
with two different funding sources
or does it does my attempt to do this
from the back of the budget cover from
judiciary
is that not in writing or what's your
back of the budget cut is not being
voted on i sent it back to lba this
morning
oh so that would have been a separate
amendment yes ma'am
now i understand thank you for helping
me understand you're welcome
representative emerick when you're ready
please call the rule
rep over yes i'm a yes representative
uh weiler i'll get it out
yeah sounds solid diverse on the way to
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch was a proponent
of gratitude to the chair
i vote yes representative walls
most definitely yes with great thanks to
the chair
and show the vote of 7-0 quota 7-0 i
have to tell you that and i didn't watch
the news last night so i don't know if
adam sexton got this on or not but he
called me about this and then
he called me back on me to do a zoom and
when i did the zoom
i made it very clear that represent mary
beth walls pushed us to look in this
direction and that the division
and i named all seven members of the
division have been working
very hard to get the budget done and we
were all unanimous about this so i made
it very clear this was a team effort
and not just my effort and then i was
going to watch the news
only somebody called me about the
training and vocational
education in the corrections and by the
time i got off the phone explaining
we had put all that back news was over
so
tracy says he didn't get on madam chair
i also spoke with adam sexton yesterday
and he indicated to me he was always
planning on putting it on today not
yesterday so i think
the day early well he called and asked
me if i
if i wanted to be on i said no he said
don't you want credit i said never it's
a team effort
he said oh well you know i'm sure you
want no and then i said yes i'll do it
because it was important that people
know we did this
now let me see what i have next
representative leishman
you're on the hook um lba will you
please bring up
2021-0806-h this is an
amendment by representative leishman
that i do think we all support this is
so madam chair i think i forwarded you
an email i received by our former
colleague
representative spanos concerning this
item and
he was very appreciative of our efforts
[Music]
again for representative weil who may or
may not be familiar with this
this is the change giving the governor
the
complete authority to dispose of the
property
in laconia as i'm sure that all of us
recall
representative spanos and mr bald were
very
supportive of establishing this
redevelopment planning commission
they've been working so they felt
kind of under cut and surprised by the
proposal basically to eliminate them and
take the authority away from the
department of administrative services to
work with them on the sale of the
laconia
property so i think that covers it madam
chair
i don't see any questions represent
weishmann would you like to move your
motion
representative leashman moves
representative emmerich seconds if
you're in the favor of the
2021 0806 h
to replace section 19 and 18
in hb2 please indicate by saying
yes when your name is called otherwise
say no
yes
representative hatch yes representative
walls
yes
the vote being seven to zero we have
approved
section 19 and hb2
now madam chair did we approve that or
did we just approve the amendment
the amendment replaces
okay mike and nancy can you bring up the
mike did you give me an hb2 amendment to
go along with this
i'm looking at the hb1 amendment is
there also an hb2 amendment
yes we just received the hb2 amendment
this morning
and i'm going to share it on the screen
okay why don't you bring up the hb1
amendment first and then we'll do
hb2
one at a section with a proration
of the money the sheriffs
finance have been a
burr under our saddle in division one
and that burr has gotten bigger
with the implementation of felonies
first
it used to be before felonies first
that the majority of those arrests
went first to district court
they were arraigned using
video arraignment i.e no transportation
of prisoners when felony first
implemented superior
chief court justice nedau
did away with video arraignments and now
in every county and of course
hillsborough where i live and where
representative leishman lives has two
courthouses so we have double the effort
double the sheriff's involved have to do
in-person arraignments
lots more transportation
since i was digging into things for
represent walls on friday i was just
kind of in a row
what are our other little horses that go
out after dark what are the nightmares
we've had that we haven't been happy
with
and i kept hearing representative hatch
and representative taberge's voices
in my head about section 1 and hb2
so i had nancy dig up the rsa for me
surprise to surprise the rsa
never said the das would pay this
so it's always been available for the
judicial branch to pay
surprise surprise the
rsa does have a statement
that says up to the funds allocated
so we have a situation that we created
one time trying to be good
that said we're gonna have das reimburse
this
and we're gonna have him do it for the
judicial branch
judicial branch never has any visibility
of the funding
never has any visibility or idea of the
consequences of their requests such as
cutting off video arraignment
and now we have this disconnect and the
sheriff's are very unhappy and two of
our representatives on this division
were very unhappy
this amendment one which is on the board
will move the money into the judicial
branch
the amendment two that will follow this
which mr hoffman said he would share on
the screen
and which none of us have seen yet
specifies in the rsa that the judicial
branch is
responsible for the reimbursement so we
don't have this disconnect again
and it also specifies that the judicial
branch
will explore using more technology
in order to cut down on some of the
transportation costs
we could go back to the video
arraignment for example
in superior court without a doubt all of
us have county
prisons that are set up with video rooms
so mr hatch
i am getting rid of that horrible
amendment you and mr tuberge didn't like
i'm putting the funding over there we
did not cut the judicial branch at in in
any way so and we gave them transfer
authority and hb2
so we know they will always have funding
to 100
fund the sheriff's mr hatch your hand is
up
just uh just again to uh thank the chair
for her
very um good and well-intended
efforts and um this is a work in
progress and again i can't thank you
enough
for your attention that's all thank you
you're welcome i'm going to
move to adam joseph weiler
representative wyler's hand was up first
representative waltz will be second
so there's nothing in the amendment that
talks about the rate they're being paid
the the hb2 has a second
amendment that addresses paying them
vis-a-vis
the contract and that is in there all
the time we have approved that
so that rsa at some point needs to be
fixed to match what we're doing in hb2
but we
we have already approved that
representative walls
thank you madam chair i'm looking at hb1
which is relevant for this purpose
because it specifically says
the state shall reimburse the sheriff's
office for court security
so this is not necessarily
transportation this is actually court
security in the courtroom during the day
i'm not arguing that we shouldn't
necessarily put it on the courts but i'm
just saying that
it's it in this case it's not about the
transportation of the prisoners it's
about the security in our courthouses
it's the transportation that has upped
the cost that is causing the heartache
because of the lack of the video
arraignment with felonies first
so we always had enough money to cover
the courthouse but it also covers the
transportation
and the transportation has gone up
significantly and i think mr hatch and
mr tuberge
both talked about the extreme distance
that you have to drive sometimes in
up in the northern counties so that
means more hours more half days more
full days
because they transport the prisoners and
then they provide the security if the
prisoners are not transported
then they do not have people in the
rooms to provide security for so it kind
of all goes together
but we know where the increase came from
that we started having the dollar amount
problem
represent patch chair yes thank you
madam chair not to belabor this
but just that we have requested
information
from the courts that's forthcoming that
will give us
uh viable factors to utilize to be fair
with this
other than just population or other
things there's a lot of
factors involved and i would appreciate
anybody's input
or help in establishing uh viable
factors that's all thank you man
and i think that's good you can continue
to look at that what this does
is remove go back to the model where
everybody was getting paid 100 percent
while you do your investigation instead
of shortening
shorting some some sheriff's
department's money
for work they're doing which i agreed
with you did not seem fair
thank you madam chair yes
to be clear just going back to hb2
there's two different provisions one on
court security and one on prisoner
custody and control would this fully
fund both
because i've heard from my own sheriff
as well as other sheriffs
about the fact they can't hire people
even at the current rate
and taking it down to 80 means they're
not going to be able to hire anybody
so i just want to make sure we're fully
funding both sections
the current rate is another section hb2
that we've approved
that says that they are paid at the same
rate
as the negotiated contract
and that's an hb2 and we voted that in
earlier
okay i'm just i'm just gonna understand
so i'm gonna move the amendment to hb1
representative emerick said he would
second
if you're in favor of the approval of
hb1 when your name is called please say
yes if you're opposed please say no
representative over yes i'm a yes
representative weiler
yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
representing walls yes i'm sure the
board is seven to zero
vote is seven to zero mike will you
share the
hb2 amendment for this and tell us what
the number is
will but may i ask a question yeah
um i just happened to notice on budget
page 76
for that sheriff's reimbursement there
is a footnote
so we would uh take the committee's
action as
also deleting that footnote just please
absolutely
0837h which does
what i explained when i gave my
explanation about the
bundle of hb1 and hp2 together
so this tells the judicial branch to
seek to use the technology
that is appropriate
and it also tells the judicial branch
that they will be reimbursing the
sheriffs for all of these fundings
which seems appropriate because the
judicial branch is the one
determining how much security they need
so again i am going to move to approve
amendment 2021 0837h
see no discussion representative emerick
when you're ready if you're in favor of
the motion please say yes
if you're opposed please say no
representative ober yes i'm a yes
representative weiler
yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yes representative walls yes
and quarter seven to zero okay
the vote is seven to zero we have a
couple of budgets that we could move to
approve
the legislative branch although it falls
under us the rsa actually says that
facilities committee
determines it so we could move to
approve that
we have also had treasury in
and we could move to approve the
treasury
representative leishman moves to approve
treasury and the legislative branch
second representative
griffin seconds if you're in favor of
approving the two branches when your
name is called
please say yes if you're opposed please
catch up with you and representative
emerick is
typing as fast as he can with these
little crayons so just bear with him
until he gets ready thank you madam
chair
representative yes i'm a yes
representative wyler
yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative patch yes
representative walls yes
and the vote is 7-0 the vote is 7-0
i have steps get completed timely yes
i have a bundle of two amendments
we are going to amend hb2 by replacing
section 60 this is amendment 2021
and then it has a companion hb1
mr hoffman will you speak to this
amendment please
represent hatcher i'm sorry your hand is
up and uh
i'm sorry it was okay
so on amendment 202108
oh
mr hoffman is going to walk us through
this i hope
yes um amendment um
that's on your screen 805 h
changes section 60 to read that
the grants for state aid which is water
projects
are suspended for the biennium including
existing and new grants i'm paraphrasing
a little bit there
then section paragraph two provides that
in the event of general fund
unrestricted revenue
coming in above plan the commissioner of
the department of administ
uh of environmental services with the
approval of fiscal committee and
governor
council can reduce requested additional
general funds
the commissioner can make those requests
every six months for the biennium
and the additional appropriations
shall not exceed 50 of the amount over
the plan
thank you mr huffman i would move the
approval of amendment 2021
0805 h represent emirates seconds
discussion
seeing none if you are in favor of the
amendment when your name is called
please say yay
if you're opposed please say nay
representative ober yes
i'm a yes representative weiler yes
representative griffin
yes representative leishman
representative hatch you're muted
sorry yes sorry representative walls
yes madam chair of the 47-0
thank you mr hoffman would you bring up
the hb1 amendment that goes along with
this please
uh yes is it visible to you now
it is thank you it may have been before
i was looking down
i not only need eyes in the back of my
head
like every mom i need a third one right
in the middle of my forehead to look up
so this amendment completes the action
we just took
and with this amendment i'm going to
move to pr approve hb1 amendment
as well as approve the des budget
second
see no discussion when representative
emerick is ready to
call the role if you're in favor of the
amendment to approve
hb1 amendment and the des budget as
amended you will say yes if you are
representative ober yes i mean yes
representative weiler
yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
the vote is seven to zero
zipping right along with the speed of a
small
elephant
yep when you have a nightmare you have a
yes okay i have an amendment for hb1
that we have clearly discussed and that
is to restore the funding
to the small business center at the
amount
of 225 000 in each
of the two years for the biennium
and lba is going to bring that up on the
this is something i think the division
was united
in doing and this fulfills
see they're struggling as much as we are
with paperwork that makes they're making
here we go so as you can see we're doing
as we discussed
previously two or three times restoring
the small business development center
funding
225 022
and again in 23 and i would move to
approve representative
c9 representative emmerich
when you're ready you can call the roll
if you're in favor when your name is
called please say yay if you're opposed
please say nay
representative ober yes i'm a yes
representative weiler yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
representative walls yes and i'm sure
the blow is 7-0
okay mike we have the second
bea hb1 amendment if you can bring that
up on the screen and i'm not sure if
that's you or nancy
to talk to it i we have
so much paperwork i've lost track you
guys have both done
great jobs
madam chair what's up on the screen i
was page two of that
change which reduced reduces the funding
for
marketing within travel and tourism to
pay for that thank you nancy
the second part of that amendment we
just voted as you know we took the money
out of travel and tourism nobody wanted
to do that the good news is
the biden coveted act
with lots of things in it besides
coverage relief
has money for travel and tourism
the governor and the budget governor's
budget director
have confirmed that there will be money
coming from the feds
we don't know how much yet and they
haven't seen the strings yet
but there will be money to beef up our
hospitality
situation the governor's budget director
is still sitting in the room he's
shaking his head yes
so we are aware that we are going to do
that this second screen was included in
the first vote thank you for pointing
you're welcome now we have the unfunds
the vacant position
i believe that's the one that i just
posted on the screen
it is you guys are magical down there i
don't know how you keep it up ken
we have an hb2 amendment
which i think you guys brought up to me
in this sheaf of paper
mama chair yes nancy you you approved
that
0738h amendment
last week thank you evans i can't find
what that did was delay the start of the
hiring
of an unclassified position director of
intergovernmental affairs until january
of 2023 but in and of itself it doesn't
save any money because the money would
be transferred from a vacant position
um within dbea so this is the peak that
makes that
um savings if you will uh happen
right okay funding the position until
thank you you're welcome i can't tell
you how much i miss having the two of
you here with us
i try not to whine too much but i think
i mentioned at least once a day
so twice and we all agree with that in
case you want to know that
thumbs go up around the table when i say
that
so it's a it's a universal wine in this
room
all right on the motion to complete our
action that we started last week
if you're in favor i will make the
motion represent emerick
seconds the motion i don't see any
discussion
if you're in favor of the motion please
say yes when your name is called
if you're not please say no
representative over
yes i mean yes representative weiler yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
representative walls
yes manager of the voice 7-0
all right with that i moved to approve
the bea
budget as amended representative griffin
seconds if you're in favor of the motion
to approve the bea budget as amended
you'll say yes when your name is called
otherwise you will say no
okay
yes yes yes
yes representative griffin
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
the mandatory vote is 7-0 vote is seven
to nothing the budget is approved
lba will you bring up the hb1 amendment
just to remind you this amendment
will ensure that we have another three
million dollars in revenue that was not
this is hp this is hb1 amendment
question represent wyler do you remember
how many auditors they have
no seem like every budget we've added
some
um this was they have a lot of vacancies
and they've unfunded some people and
to me the governor's projected plan he
didn't take into account their revenue
and he took out two more and we're
restoring them
does it make money because they make
money and we need the three million
bucks
i am going to move to approve the hb1
amendment adding to auditors and to
approve the dra
budget as amended
we've discussed this so i don't see any
additional hands up
on the motion to approve the hb1
amendment and to approve the dra budget
as amended if you're in favor please say
yes if you're opposed please say no
representative ober yes i mean yes
representative weiler
yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
representative walls
yes i'm sure the vote is seven to zero
uh right on the back jenna will do it
sorry
page 68 and hb2
for some reason we just hadn't
approved
representative leashman moves approval
this is the judicial council
expenditures and i will second that
discussion
cnn representative emerick on the motion
to approve
section 159 for the judicial council in
hb2
if you're in favor please say yes when
your name is called if you're opposed
please say no
representative ober yes i mean yes
representative weiler
yes representative griffin yes
representative lishman yes
representative hatch
yes representative walls yes
okay
mary beth i think i have another one of
this is your amendment mary beth that
you've been working on with kim
merrifield on that uh section 128
the language that there was a concern
about
so this has your name on it i think you
have a
i'd like to move it and speak to it yep
i will second your motion represent
walsh
moves and represent over seconds and
represent walls is going to speak to her
motion
so this amendment is not exactly the
language that i wanted commissioner
maryfield came up with language that i
thought was better and then ols
said you can't do it so i kind of view
ols as god in these things and god had
spoken
so i worked with ols to come up with
additional language
as you may recall the problem was is
that they're stopped
sending notices
return receipt requested and therefore
they have no idea if the
service has been completed upon people
from whom they want to take away
benefits
and i think that you should not be
taking benefits away unless somebody's
been notified
so this happens and i wasn't even sure
of this when i started this this happens
to apply to workman's comp and in most
cases with workman's comp there's been a
decent back and forth
but if somebody moves and they for
whatever reason don't have a forwarding
address or don't have a fixed address to
have a forwarding address i wanted some
time to happen
so what it says is in you know you can
read it but what it basically says
is is that if you don't have service you
have to do it send a return receipt
requested if that doesn't happen
it gives the department a year to try
and find
the claimant and notify them that
there's going to be
some sort of problem with their benefits
and that during that year they're
supposed to make
appropriate attempts to contact the
claimant and if at the end of the year
they can't find the claimant
then they can just issue an order
of not in favor of the claimant in other
words where the claimant loses
and it seemed to me that this was a
reasonable compromise kind of a fair
compromise of protecting the climate
but not leaving a des or
in a situation where they've got cases
open forever
[Music]
i don't see any questions represented
walls can ask you to
amend your motion would you move to
approve this amendment
and to approve the labor department's
budget says this
will close that out i do i hereby move
both the amendment and the budget
okay i will second both of those if
you're in favor of approving amendment
2021-0813h
will say yes when your name is called if
you are opposed you will say no
and the clerk will call the rule
representative ober
yes i mean yes representative weiler yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes representative
walls
yes i'm sure the vote is six
seven to zero okay
i have one last little bundle we're
going to do
it's two amendments um the first one is
two zero two one oh eight zero
zero h we're going to be on page
hb1 or hp2 madam chair hb2 i apologize
[Music]
did you both get one yeah
mike you have it up on the board thank
you
okay
the governor section 122 if you're
looking at the governor has proposed
and by the way this has gone to carol
mcguire
at edna and has the edna
seal of approval which i got back
monday um
line 29 the adult parole board shrinks
from nine to five
to which she'll be attorneys there's a
composition
of the board doesn't stay
doesn't have any change most of this is
page two line one the governor was
proposing
30 000 a year without mileage
i've lowered that annual stipend to 20
000 a year
keeping in mind that we are making small
get through the years the board will
hold 36 days of hearings
etc so all of that is the same except
representative leishman moves
representative over seconds the approval
of
a doc motion amendment two zero two one
zero
eight h zero zero h
somehow that's hard to say zero eight
zero zero h
okay representative emery have i
stuttered around long enough you can
call the rule
does that include the budget of no it
does not i have another amendment
okay representative ober yes i mean yes
representative
weiler yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yes representative walls yes
i'm sure the vote is seven to zero okay
seven to zero the next section turn the
page to page
amendment20210794h
we are going to delete
the director of operations
as a from
from this point i think
uh the answer mike who did this
previously we made that person 50
and adjusted the salary in doc is that
correct
or did we just delete this person
altogether
this is the new position never mind i
remember
this is the brand new position for the
biennium
they're just going to have to do without
him it adds too much cost
again yeah
excuse me um the position please help
the position exists as a um
executive assistant now and this is the
name of the position to director of
operations
and when i looked in the system the
salary is very close for the two
this would be more of a formal naming of
that position
actually this did not have
a policy review
which edna should have done so where
they can file a bill next year they can
run through edna
so i moved to approve section
2021-0794-h
representative emmerich seconds seeing
no discussion
will the clerk call the rule
representative over yes i'm a yes
representative weiler
yes representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
representative walls
yes i'm sure the vote is 7-0
all right the vote is 7-0 the
we have lots more work we aren't going
to be doing it today
we have the public hearing starting at
one o'clock
um i think representative wyler and
several people are going to be
in reps hall several people are going to
be
hybriding in remote so today
that's today isn't it that is today
please tell me that this is timekeepers
i think we'll be done with the majority
of our work
tomorrow and if you're sitting in this
room
check your email make your lunch order
with nancy lunch is on me
mike hoffman mike kane you should check
your email
get your sandwich order to janet lunches
on me
nancy if you want to come in it's on me
as well i just don't have any way of
emailing you a sandwich
although bill hatch is helping me figure
out how to email him some beefeater's
gin so
we got that working i don't know what
mary beth has got in hand but
something i did post a
hearing a week from today and the reason
is
representative major is working
diligently tomorrow on new revenue
estimates
he is also working on the tax session
sections in hb2 that belong to us
he will be able to tell us
where he and his committee stand on that
um so that we can
go ahead and finalize our work
next tuesday oh i had one more amendment
i wanted to vote in before we go so
don't
hang up now i'm leafing through my
oh amazing keep track of it all oh yeah
yeah yeah well it took here we go mike
this is this year's
house bill 686 which came out of ways
and means
with a recommendation of 19 to 2.
i understand last biennium it also
passed out of ways and means
however it got bundled into one of those
infamous omnibus
bills at the end of the year that did
not
get past the governor's red pin because
of everything in the bills this is
a bill this replicates word for word
the historic racing bill that ways and
means has been working on for i think
about
six years together
i have urging from ways and means to
include
into the budget it gives us an
additional
oh yay representative burge is alive in
here
we do have a meeting one o'clock we had
a meeting at 10 o'clock we were worried
like crazy about you we thought your
shot had
done you win okay we're not that lucky
oh oh did i miss something no come down
and sit we're going to take one more
vote
and one o'clock you need we need help at
one o'clock too so i'll tell you about
it come sit down
all right so this
puts word for word that bill that's come
out of ways and means
we get 24 million dollars of revenue
that revenue unfortunately does not
greatly benefit us
it benefits the education fund because
it goes into lottery but that's okay
anything we do to help education we've
heard some of the pleas from some of the
other people
i think we are in favor of that we had a
bill on that that got retained so we
know we need to somehow benefit
so i've been asked to put this in and
i'm going to move the
adoption of 2021 85h
representative emerick ii madam chair
yes you happen to hit something that i
know a great deal about
and i'm glad to hear that and i actually
think that you
have misstated what happened in the last
two years and i know that because i was
on the floor with it
both times and the story is that the
bills came out of ways and means
ought to pass and eventually there was a
floor fight of which i led the
opposition to it
and fortunately was successful in both
years so
in neither year is my understanding did
historic racing
pass and so i'm not sure what where it
might have passed because i can assure
you that in the floor fight
both times i prevailed so i am
only repeating the information i got
from ways and means i don't recall this
bill
at all however we've been asked to put
it in by ways and means
if they gave me some bum information i
can apologize represent walls but i did
not research it i would use
my colleague's information i understand
that but i'm gonna
severely oppose this this body
legislature does not approve of this and
we have
turned it down not just the last two
years but
every single year before that this is
totally contrary to what this
legislature has done and it was not a
partisan issue
it was a bipartisan and when i was on
the floor there were republicans
standing next to me opposing this as
well
so i think that it's really
inappropriate to be putting it in when
the legislature
bipartisanly has so consistently opposed
this
i understand the desire for finding more
revenue but i think this is not an
appropriate way to do it
i think that there are huge problems
with this there's huge problems with the
companies being brought in to run it
and i think that this is being brought
in now without a public hearing
and i think that's a it had a public
hearing it's house bill 686
it had a public hearing in ways and
means this year
but i'm also telling you that the floor
that the body itself has opposed what
the committee has done
every single time without exception or
we would have historic racing
and we don't and i think that it's a
huge
problem to be bringing this in and
burying it here in hb2 this is
let's just let it go through or be
debated as a bill
and not try and circumvent the regular
bill process on such an important change
to our laws
thank you for your comments i was asked
by the speaker and republican leadership
to bring this forward it has passed out
of ways and means
with a 19 to 2 recommendation it has had
a public hearing
i appreciate your comments this is where
we are
the motion the amendment has been moved
and seconded
if you're in favor of amendment 202106
h5h
when your name is called please say yes
if you are opposed please say no
yes
representative walls no okay the motion
passes six to one
we are going to reconvene in rep's hall
at one o'clock thank you for your work
morning